what do you think of Taylor Swift now re
recording everything so that she can own
it right she's so smart she's so great
she's a genius really I mean look at
what she's doing that's amazing but
that's a way to do it and I've done a
lot of that myself in the last several
years to re-record a lot of the stuff
that I did um you know that that were on
other labels so you can you can do that
also do you ever think about pulling out
those cozy sweats and just kicking back
at a certain point is that ever in your
future or no no I've never once thought
that I would retire now I I have said
that I might have slowed down and might
have to quit for a time if my husband
was sick or if I was physically ill but
that would be the only thing that would
ever stop me is if I you know if
something really bad that just Tri me up
that I couldn't overcome but I would
still try to find ways to work around it
oh I just love love what I do yeah I
always say I'm made of music I'm made of
dreams I'm made of uh I'm made of love
and all of those things together like
always say people say how do you do it
how do you keep going I said because I
live on creative and spiritual energy
and that is a powerful force you know
and I and I mean that's how I know it's
just like a wheel inside of me are you
the kind of person that after a few days
if you say oh I really need this for
myself I now know my bandwidth I need to
recharge my batteries within a few days
you just start getting itchy and ideas
and before you know it you're reaching
out to everybody again well I get the
ideas even if I'm you know I can't out
my mind I don't even try to go on
vacations CU I can't stand it you know
the vacation to me is just getting to
stay home few days and just to cook kick
back but I'm still got a notepad
somewhere some my my mind still goes but
that's it's a way of life with me it's
not tiring to me I've often said it's my
joy and my
[Music]
job